[Music]
all right for those of you guys who
don't know i know these guys already
know we just want to see what they think
dave chappelle was set to perform at
this venue called first avenue in
minneapolis
and then the venue cancelled on him what
they were caving into the leftist
protest that he was spreading uh
transhaven i saw this [ __ ] dude like
was it a comedy club or what was this
theater venue yeah the theater so they
were okay so there was a venue and dave
chappelle was supposed to do a show
there and they said we're canceling yeah
and then i didn't know the reason why
but it was because they said they call
them an anti-trans man they don't like
money or what no they said the first
first avenue was theater they were
quoted as saying like oh first avenue is
more than just a a box with people in it
we have like values as well
here you community and we want to do
what's right i never thought that there
would be a day where dave chappelle
would be the poster boy of [ __ ]
straight up
xenophobic like i know
anti-trans like
that's so [ __ ] weird i think they're
just right honestly i think they're
really forcing it yeah they really are
people are not they're not you're not
even watching the special that's what
i'm saying just watch the joke watching
yeah like because he dude that that's
honestly when i watch that [ __ ] actually
kind of made me tear up yeah yeah it was
a very powerful story that everyone puts
into question about like the trans bit
that he did right i felt like he did a
really good job of balancing the nuance
of
how complex that topic is and then also
making jokes because that's what it is
he's making jokes at the end of the day
i just like adding uh trans to every
word
i just heard trans hate trans man
transatlantic
you know
transatlantic that's my favorite
transaction transaction
transam yeah
trans fat real bad real bad transplants
bad food yeah trans fat you eat it turns
into protein later but the thing is
so i i kind of
you know when when he first got canceled
or whatever by lgbtq or whatever right
and then so like i actually wanted to
see
if this is something that i need to like
get schooled on because i don't really
know the community but when i went on
the forums and saw this stuff they don't
even agree um like like they like
there's trans people that are and
there's also gay people that are like
nah dude he's [ __ ] cool like
they're just jokes and like you guys
need to [ __ ] get a grip and then the
people that are trying to cancel them
are like no [ __ ] that he's like saying
and i'm like well if the community
doesn't agree then how come
only one section only gets
representation because that's like if
someone made an asian joke right and
then like maybe like three asians were
angry but like most asians were like nah
dude just [ __ ] chill it was a good
joke then it's like who do you listen to
well the white people get mad you know
that's the white people yeah that's like
sure
maybe it's the white people the straight
white people that are speaking on behalf
of all the minorities there's a lot of i
don't understand that what do you you
don't want this battle save us dude they
have to save us
to save all of us they're only open
hope there were some really good uh
quotes from like other comedians about
what happened and uh i think was uh
piscopo someone said this they said that
like oh this is just a demonstration
where
um
people think that by canceling on you
that they now have the power that you
have oh yeah but it's an illusion it's
like you'll never have it that's where
cancel that's where that comes from yeah
because and also like comedians are so
tight that if dave chappelle doesn't get
allowed there then there goes probably
joe rogan like all his other friends
that go down the list and then now that
that first avenue is probably going to
go out of business like nobody's going
to do [ __ ] they were saying too they
were like uh first avenue deserves to
fail now
well they might have other shows because
it's not just a box full of people
they're gonna have puppet shows
there's also that really like there's a
very very difficult thing like if you
cave into like far left uh agenda
you'll be held to an impossible standard
yeah you will never be able to beat it
you can never be when i was in high
school all the way up until college the
far left was cool as [ __ ] dude they were
so cool and then for some reason
it turned into a bunch of hall monitors
like they used to be the one that was
like
that's the best way to explain it yeah
dude that's what we identified as back
then yeah like more like rage right like
right against the stream yeah they're
anti-government now they're
pro-government they're like pro-fucking
establishment i'm like what the [ __ ] is
happening it's all over the place it
really is there was another quote that i
thought was really great somebody said
that if you walk in
and we're making fun of you now you're
accepted among
everybody in that room because
everyone's being made fun of yeah but if
you're being put to your own little
corner yeah we're like oh we're not
going to make fun of you because you're
lesser
and you're more sensitive
that's whack yeah for everybody bro
everyone gets it
that's why you get dunked on sometimes i
feel like far left is so racist because
like they think that all minorities are
a bunch of victims that need saving and
all this [ __ ] and i'm like dude speak
for your [ __ ] self bro both sides are
racist yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
the far right
[Laughter]
most of us in the middle here we don't
want to [ __ ] deal with that [ __ ]
let's get the right and the left that
are like on the farthest corners and let
them [ __ ] and like go over somewhere
else that's what makes it difficult that
both sides want to kick our asses right
yeah
and that's the thing with this whole
trans thing like for me personally is is
like it's
depending on which statistic you believe
it's one percent of the population
but it's actually way less than one
percent because they're i think they're
also including people that are thinking
about it or whatnot but the actual
transplant i think it's like way less
than one it might even be like whatever
like half a percent or like less than
half a percent and so hey i understand
that they're marginalized and they get
bullied i get that but what about like
let's just go with black people
black people have been marginalized for
decades
yeah it's like okay you know what let's
put black people aside because but let's
worry about the
like let's i'll give them one percent
let's worry about the one percent and
that's fine they should be protected but
then if you're skipping over other
marginalized groups just to protect this
this one group it's like hey i know it's
heroic and it makes you feel heroic but
come on there's a lot of um i don't want
to say larger issues or bigger issues
because we got to get a line though yeah
you do got to get in line
there's a line and i really feel like
black people are at the forefront of the
line you know because of the whole i
don't know slavery thing
you know and the whole and you know now
when they talk about racism they they
the more modern definition racism is
institutional oppression
so like if someone accuses me of being
racist that's actually a misnomer it's
more like i'm prejudiced because i don't
i'm not an institution yeah right and so
when they bring that up you know so like
to me like i feel like black people are
number one in that line
and you know you can argue with me
whatever you want but i would say native
americans and black people probably need
the most attention first yeah and then
the the asians that do need help are the
jungle asians yes we need to help the
jungle asian i'm just touching the sides
of my head
you can do it it's okay we give you
permission
you know like we you know like these uh
us we're not even marketed to it just
gets worse
it's getting way worse
over there
because the thing about us
and the thing is everyone knows what you
mean
everyone knows it's not even like
what does he mean by that i do like
racist physical gestures because you get
right away yeah is transgenders like
that
you can't is that that version of this
or no
it hasn't even been made up yet yeah
they haven't got one yet yeah or is it
something you should that's another
thing to focus on yeah we gotta figure
out is it like
the brand name we gotta get the branding
right you know
scott window right everybody has a
physical yeah i'm going hey hey
and i'm like what see let's not
establish it oh okay um
[Laughter]
that's how that's how racist uh deaf
people
yeah all right i have a theory though
about chappelle so you know chappelle
started like working out after the
chappelle show he got a [ __ ] guy
his voice got deeper and raspier than a
lot of cigarettes are we might be maybe
it comes with age i don't know
but um i have a black comic friend i
won't say his name um but he's a large
imposing figure and he's always like man
you know it sucks you know you know i'm
not getting the opportunities a lot of
these guys are getting i'm like you know
i'll tell you straight cause i used to
work in tv development you're a scary
black man you're not scary you're nice
you're a really nice gentle guy but they
don't know that you're an imposing big
black man but you take these some of
these other black comics that are like
skinny
and the developed people are like you
know they won't they don't ever say it
it's probably subconscious like i could
take this guy i'm not i'm not worried
about this guy so when chappelle took me
when chappelle got picked up kevin hart
kind of yeah kevin he's like cute and
like exactly yeah and you could and
kevin's short kevin's like five four
five five you feel like you can pick him
up put him on your shoulders and walk
around he's spunky exactly spunky spunky
yeah they love that guy
buff
um because i don't think i mean i know
his material has changed obviously it's
evolved but as soon as he got buff
he got intimidated yeah a lot more
people he got because of his
intimidation a lot more people have been
coming after him and then because
imagine if chappelle was still skinny
and he had that little high-pitched
voice like he did early on in his career
or earlier
around that time or like killing me
softly like that kind of imagine using
the same material i don't know that the
backlash would be as big because it's
not as imposing not as imposing yeah
that's really good i've never heard that
uh take that's cool do you think uh but
having like let's say like the mark
twain award you think that like because
now he's like a award-winning comedian
oh yeah doesn't that i don't know have
some sort of like it's like having like
wreaths next to your film he's on a
pedestal yeah like is that do you think
that astrid or takes away from it i
think for comedians it adds to it like
when we look at it but like for the
layperson they probably have never heard
of the mark twain award and even if they
will they google it and they google
they're like oh i don't care whatever he
doesn't like trans people so i like
forget dave chappelle but dave chappelle
is the spearhead of comedy again like
like he is the guy that once he came
back and he's and people start hearing
how much money he's gotten
how like even more of a figure he is and
more people are talking about a stand-up
and like the zeitgeist i guess i think
that takes it to another level where
people are like he's the target kind of
like joe rogan right right
everybody references joe rogan he's the
guy so then what does cnn do they're
like we're gonna [ __ ] dunk on this
yeah the way that dave moves
him coming back
it's also in a way of like i figured the
game out yeah yeah and i won he's all
wise as [ __ ] dude yeah like i and i'm
gonna i it's my show and i'm gonna take
it like the way that he's like saying
these things and then like smoking a
cigarette too like lighting it on stage
for the mark twain award just like
ashton getting on the stage like he's
really just like walking all over this
industry being like y'all [ __ ] me but i
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of y'all
you know what i'm saying yeah that's
true because all the when he left and he
did uh after he got the chappelle show
around the third season and he was like
i'm out and they offered him what like
hundreds of millions of dollars 50
million 50 million right and everybody
was like oh dave chappelle's crazy he
got a lot of backlash for that and when
he dipped out and people were waiting
like where's dave chappelle oh oh wait
he's doing this stand-up show in the
park yeah oh that's crazy oh wait wait
we gotta go we gotta go he builds up his
hype and then he's gone for a while
because i think by nature he's very low
key he doesn't want to be
in the front stage like that but then
what he wants to do is share his comedy
and now his style of comedy changed so
much where he's almost like
in that george carlin-esque
where he's talking about life he's
talking about
regular things and he's he's so much
more than just a comedian now he's a
storyteller he's he's like defining
culture for a lot of people straight up
so yeah that makes him a target i think
on top of everything else when you watch
his last few specials i mean i'll be
honest i didn't laugh a lot i enjoyed
them but i didn't laugh like smiling
like yeah but you know you but if you
watch something like i'll just use kevin
hart as an example
you laugh a lot you know and so i to me
like chappelle like you were saying
chris i think like he's just kind of
transcended the whole stand-up comedy
thing and he's up there he's almost like
a philosopher to a certain degree yeah
yeah
and we're expected to laugh and so
because respected life we watch it we're
like oh it was a great special one of
the best specials that's like but how
many times did you laugh yeah yeah you
know if you're gonna go like our job is
still to make people laugh at the end of
the day the lines get blurred it gets
blurred yeah and then like imagine chris
if you or i had chappelle's script
before he did before he performed and we
performed it
dude you have any jokes like what are
you doing dude that's true
and then people that are watching it
whether they are watching or not because
i'm sure the people that are mad at him
a good percentage of those people
actually didn't watch the thing and
they're just like reacting to it yeah
that's what i'm saying but because it's
a little more serious tone i think some
people that don't understand comedy
which is a big amount of people right
they might take it as like oh he's not
even joking like he's being [ __ ] for
real there's a headline with damon
williams saying uh is he doing stand-up
comedy or speeches that's what he did i
was just like i mean
he's doing funny speeches yeah you're
doing funny speeches yeah exactly
[Music]